so the early reviews are coming in for
the film john and and the critics are
calling this the perfect blockbuster how
do you digest that
well it's that's that's certainly good
news i think that this is a movie that
you want to see in theaters and it feels
like a welcome back to the theaters
after a couple years of uh of pause that
we were all on and i think when uh when
people start seeing this in the theaters
and they see it big and loud and they
understand what kind of experience it is
they they're gonna forget about the last
two years and they're gonna start going
back to theaters so i hear mr cruz is
going to have an epic arrival and i
think that he's doing it right now
well i mean
there's only one of those guys and here
he comes the best right do you get any
better than that i don't i don't know
i'm just glad he's going through the
back of my shot so that's perfect for me
it is perfect timing exactly exactly
oh good
just got to watch in awe sometimes at
how this guy does i like that he ordered
up the weather for today that was very
nice of him too
here he comes
we got drones we got helicopters we got
aircraft carriers this is insane
i love it
i love it no we're good
this might be a little bit of a reaction
when he gets out of the shop
i'm wondering if he's the pilot on that
thing it's a very good question i'm sure
he's sitting in the front seat
there we go
[Applause]
movie star with a capital m and a
capital s
getting out of pilot seat there he is
out of the pilot seat
left seat left seat
so good he did it himself so good he did
it himself
you don't get better than that no i love
that we did play-by-play for it
wouldn't have it any other way okay now
john listen
you had perfection with you tonight
i mean
she's perfect
i'm sure you're talking about me i
thought you're doing with me all right
no it was your beautiful day yeah so
that's my girlfriend anna we've been
together for some time now it's a nice
nice nice to be on an aircraft carrier
with a nice little young lady like that
nice to have a good date night you know
what i'm saying get dressed up put it
the best this might be the best date
night i think i could even come up with
[Music]
you